some resistance is always good for art I
think Michelangelo has this big block of
marble and he needs to dig David out of
there right not only does he need to do
you know chip away just the right amount
of marble but he has to then you know
find this thing in there and then he has
to smooth that out making it perfect
right
if Dave if Michelangelo was given a
marble that Dave just comes away really
what did he have been better sculptor
you don't I mean there's something about
the having to navigate just being like I
don't think I can do this I think it's a
great push for an artist this is gonna
be impossible I think sometimes it can
sharpen your vision I wrote and directed
bootytime I already shot it and it was
during the editing process you I got
flown out to LA I have no idea well I
can I smelled something but yeah they
took me to Paris and I went to John
Goldman's office he was Samuel Goldwyn
grandson and so I'm in his office I mean
the most important office at Paramount
he was running the studio the timing I
remember I walked in and he's shaking a
little he's so mad everybody was there
that was involved in the movie he
unloaded on me and said this movie is
unreleasable you have wasted my money
this is irresponsible I have a problem
with everyone here and then this guy who
was the president of MTV Films yeah they
said well John I don't think you really
got the film how dare you say that never
forget that moment cuz I wanted to do is
make movies at the time and that was
being destroyed by Samuel Goldwyn
screams oh and I'm sitting there but a
part of me was outside of my body going
you are in the the Paramount big office
being yelled at by so how cool is it I
was able to enjoy it who gets to have
that's very rare beautiful experience to
get to have it to me that the key is
like surviving failure it's a very great
experience quietly and thinking about
how you can apply them to your business
and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]